oh I wanted to ask you about my salary I
don't think it's a very touchy subject
around here you have to take that up
with our boss Mr Hart oh I'm sorry it's
also new don't worry you're going to get
the hang of it then you'll really be
sorry
that of course is Jane Fonda and Lily
Tomlin in the classic movie nine to five
uh the very first film they made
together that was more than 40 years ago
they are an award-winning Duo and
they've been close friends ever since
then they've collaborated on a whole
bunch of major projects including the
popular very popular TV series Grace and
Frankie which ended last year after
seven seasons it's a very good run and
now they are teaming up for another film
this time a comedy a dark comedy it's
called moving on and the two play Claire
and Evelyn who reunite at the funeral of
a friend and decide to kill the friend's
husband as one does yes why not the
reason why is not revealed until later
in the film but in the clip you're about
to see they call they try uh they could
call him to try and meet up so they can
carry out execute their plan
yeah I um I feel
bad you know Howard I want to come over
and apologize in person
apologize for what threatening to kill
me no
for that
all right well apology accepted I just I
feel
crazy I've been just crazy Howard
just a crazy woman you know I it must be
the stress I've been under a lot of
stress
Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin join us now
uh ladies thank you very much for being
here the movie's very funny yeah um and
the the threat of murder comes very
early on I think at the funeral in fact
um and uh and there's a bit of suspense
throughout too because you're walking
around with murder weapons at various
times and I'm wondering as I'm watching
is it going to happen now is it going to
happen now uh but Lily you actually
called the director as I understand it
correct me if I'm wrong and requested a
script for you two to star in a movie
together well maybe requested is true
danger word I I probably begged him no I
I just said Paul come on why don't you
write a movie for me in Jane why were
you so excited to work with Jane well
because it's just so natural and easy
and we've known each other and people
say we have chemistry we don't know why
or how but it all works for us so I say
okay you you don't you guys definitely
have chemistry Jane and I found myself
laughing and thinking now it's about a
murder but it's also a comedy did you
think did you find it funny when you
were doing it because it's it is as Tony
said very funny but it's also very
serious because it raises all sorts of
serious issues about why character yeah
that's very serious about why she wanted
to kill well it shows you that I have no
sense of humor I didn't know that it was
and you know originally in in the
original script the first words out of
my mouth are I'm gonna kill you yes or
do it this weekend yes I mean for me it
was like a major I'm actually waited 45
years to say this and I saw the movie
with an audience and they laughed and I
thought well there it goes
were you surprised when the audience
started laughing I was shocked I thought
I'd failed no you probably knew that I
knew I died she's funny no but I knew
what was funny and I knew and when you
play it straight really heavy it makes
it much funnier yeah so you're kind of
you're arrogant in it you're everything
you're it's it's amazing how do you
explain though guys the magic between
the two of you when you first started
working together did you like each other
right away did you know each other
before you started well you go back
years ago as a star yeah you know and I
was uh sure I was crazy about her and
she and I in fact I had a clued hairdo
for a couple of years did you did you
really yeah wow so that really showed
she loved it
in the back of my YouTube that album I
have a flute hairdo uh-huh I have I I
looked almost as well as you you liked
her right away Jane what was your
impression of Lily Thomas we'll see it
started years ago the reason that we
worked together in nine to five was I I
went and saw her in appearing nightly as
a one-woman show where she plays a lot
of different characters but it's not
yeah in search of signs of intelligent
life so I went down to the almondsen
here and I saw her and I I that was it I
was in love I mean I just I've never
seen anything like it she became so many
different people and and just became
them profoundly
became them yeah I mean everything about
her changed with each character and I
just I I just thought well I'm not going
to make a movie about secretaries unless
she's in it I don't want to ever do
anything without her I just Will Smith
speaking of that I love that speaking of
that amazing movie about secretaries
nine to five we had that opening clip uh
if you guys happen to catch it if it's
on TV or someone else is watching it
what do you think all these years later
I think it's good it holds up yeah it's
very funny
and it makes me feel good because we had
such a good time making it that every
time I see anything to do with it like
what's showing right now I get really
happy yeah we made friends with Dolly
and Jane and I all made friends and it
was just sort of it it was cool we were
all the friendly type but you started
shooting this movie shortly after Grace
and Frankie uh wrapped up yeah did you
just want to start working again neither
one of you thought you know what after
seven successful Seasons we deserve a
break that's just 10 days right yeah
yeah it was it was 10 days neither one
of you thought you know let's go on
vacation let's just hang out there was
no time it's just that's how it turned
out you know I was ready to do it he
needed to do it in that time and so we
had to do it and yet one of the things I
read Lily is that you once you take on
something you then start to sort of
second-guess yourself and you think to
yourself maybe I'm not good oh my God
how does that make you feel like you're
requesting the movie demanding it
begging well I've been trying to get out
of this one because I had done that
although I did talk to him about you
know seeming like I was like the E
Garden of the movie
when you say oh my God yeah I want to
Second guesses herself yeah because I
learned from the First with nine to five
on the second day she asked to be let
out of her contract she couldn't do it
on the second day yeah
wow and we said no I was one of the
producers and I said no you know almost
about the about what was going through
your mind well because I just saw I had
done the I shot the animation first and
without any objects there you know like
the little bird and the little spoon I
stir the coffee it was and I thought I'm
just so leddon yeah so Daddy I I just
can't do that I said I'm I'm I just was
sure I was
going to be
bad news in the movie but she always
does this then I discovered she that's
her what the process it's the process
yeah uh you know the process of being
friends for 40 years involves getting on
each other's nerves I imagine one guess
is at some point so what what is the
secret to the kind of longevity when I
imagine when she's you're a producer on
the movie and she's like I'm done I need
to be out of it you're frustrated a
little bit no I talk very calmly and
respectfully I went to Bruce first to
Bruce Gilbert who was my partner her
partner and I said uh Bruce I'm not
really good in this movie I can just see
it all coming down the hill it's it's
starting to ambulance toward me and I
said it'd be better or get out now and
you won't don't have to pay me anything
uh just will part agreeably and someone
else will film those scenes with the
bird and the spoon and you also both of
you have lives off camera I mean Jane
you're known as a feminist known as an
activist do you see yourself that way
yes you do
yeah thank you God
no but I've heard you say that you got
into it late which is because as long as
long as I've seen you that way too yeah
I'm like I'm late at everything but so
what's nice is that for 30 years I was
not an activist yeah I was in that place
that so many people are saying who am I
what what's my purpose in life there's
no meaning in my life and um
so I know what that feels like yeah it's
not like I was always an activist and
then activism meant the world to me I
suddenly knew who I was and
one of the issues so I think the voice
is needed I think it is needed and now
your voice you're using it we had a
picture there of you at the un uh you're
calling for Action to prevent continued
climate change the warming when I spoke
recently at the U.N that was
to urge the delegates just to create a
global oceans treaty it's the biggest
conservation win in history
yeah but our ocean the deep seas which
used to be the wild west there will now
be Law and Order yeah but when you walk
in a room people want to hear what you
have to say I mean I think when you
speak up it matters to many people but I
look at the two of you together are you
thinking should we wind down our career
you're thinking what are you both
sitting here thinking what can we do
next Lily
the ladder what can we do next what can
we do now yeah that was the ladder yeah
Lily and I and I have to kind of go
along with whatever Jane wants to do on
an activism level yeah even if I have to
just present her with another award
or IU I present you
I don't know getting a mobile for the
things that you two do never seems old
to me I think it's a great partnership
it's a great friendship especially
especially Virginia did you like this
movie that we're doing I love it the
movie's called moving on very much very
funny it's only a little bit dark and
suspenseful you guys are terrific in it
together
really truly if you want to catch it in
theaters Fonda thank you very much for
being here uh March 17th see it in a
movie theater or a change that's right
yeah best way to see it all right these
days yeah you can do that while you
still can